Hot Sauce we go crazy what is that dude
we're changing the channel name you
probably picked this up in the
background watching our videos who
talking about different names of the
channel so this channel is no longer
just me and Sam there's a whole
wonderful cast of characters and amazing
people working on this channel people
who are fun to watch charismatic and
have something to teach all of us so
it's about time that we updated our
branding from the Sam and eco channel to
the corridor crew so in one week
the channel name will flip over so don't
be surprised when you see it called the
corridor crew don't think that it's only
you've been subscribed to a random new
channel it's this channel so enjoy the
corridor crew
oh and if you haven't subscribed well
then now is a great time to do so old
tips I think so ancient ships
we filled away this hot sauce right here
I haven't opened it yet but it's called
the last dad this is one of the hottest
hot sauces in the world no it has a
Scoville level of something like about
two and a half million now this is from
the the YouTube show hot ones from first
week feast it's one of my favorite
YouTube shows i watch it every single
week just by coincidence I happen to
taste this last week just a drop on the
top of burrito and take it buy it I go
holy [ __ ]
no hot sauces ever made me do that by
the way okay there's a lot of hot sauces
out there that are total [ __ ]
because they put in chili extracts or
like capsaicin oil or whatever that
stuff is anything about like chili
extracts or oils that are put in throw
it away it's not real hot sauce it needs
to be made with the actual peppers this
hot sauce happens to be legit yeah this
hot sauce specifically is made from the
Moruga scorpion pepper which is a very
hot pepper it's not the hottest pepper
that's the pepper ex I don't deal with
super spicy food very well I'm going no
chip hey we're all gonna do this dose
yes yes yes yes I'm giving everyone the
same dab they do on the show a little
bit more than everyone has oh it's the
competition I want to win I'm doing
salsa hot sauce I'm not a too big of a
fan we go first
first game I just had a bunch of salsa
right now you just won't hold your gummy
it's a gut bomb dude how spicy you say
that's you I see I see sweat
I didn't sweat it marks from camera
being on I'm gonna give it some air that
the breathe
that's they'll help the spice gonna keep
in my mouth a little bit more give me
more
okay I'm just gonna I'm only gonna I'm
only gonna bite this part of the choke a
it's actually starting to build a little
bit but I can totally tell I got a big
thought this was death blow I think
everybody's like leaving me underwhelmed
it was just eat it tastes good but no
it's hot
does it creep up on you yeah it's a joke
keep going
Thanks
that's like what's a good sauce thank
you you know you wanna have something
spicy no claim feud I had to think dad
you want some spice someone try this
oregano oil if you want a spicy
experience I'll take some drops of that
I almost thought I was having an
allergic reaction can you share that you
might remember us talking about a
Chromebook project we were working on
we're going to a meeting about that very
project because we have an idea that
we're gonna be pitching them
it's called janky Qian people basically
said hey we like what you guys do we
want to support it how can we support
you to make a video that you probably
otherwise wouldn't be able to make and
we have this really crazy idea now in
exchange for them helping us with that
video we're gonna help them with a brand
video where they're basically going to
show off what it's like a day in the
life of port or digital making a video
much like we did last year now the big
question is whether or not they'll
approve this idea so every single time
someone calls us up and said hey guys we
like your videos we want to work with
you or sponsored video let's work
together they're always looking at our
previous work they're like oh you'll
make a video like real GTA and then
we'll sponsor it's like well we already
made that video we have to make a new
video now guys and so every single time
we meet with people like this it's it's
always a challenge because we're always
trying to convince them hey here's a new
idea we're starting from scratch every
time that's the definitely the big
challenge Minh pitches like this yeah so
today we convinced Google why Jackie
Chan a glitching 3d model is going to be
the face of their new Chromebook no Jack
you can't everyone knows Jackie Chan
everyone knows that Hong Kong style even
if they don't know that it's that's
where it originated they know that's
what they get when they've watched
Jackie Chan so if you put the name janky
can you get the Joker right away no you
could expand on that title maybe a
little bit but the simplicity of that
tends to hit home pretty
we're using this glitch as part of the
fight choreography he's trying to fight
them off each time he does it's a
different glitch somebody's in a
headlock right and you need the motion
I'm getting shaken and stuff make me
something work practically on set you
film somebody holding something in the
headlock and the person and headlocks in
like a green war suit you know so you
have the practical element there and
then you use computer you race person in
green war suit or can you reach it down
to pull a carpet out from like under the
boss's feet and like the carpet is like
slides off like with his legs still
attached and the boss still attached and
everything we're like maybe we do the an
actual practical carpet pull but then
they like the two legs are you know a CG
element that are placed on top for the
most part we tried to have our shots be
half real and half CG we went in there
they loved the idea we talked all about
it now we're gonna get to it we're just
waiting on them to get back to us with
some things that they want to focus on
and they're behind the scenes and then
we're gonna finish writing the script
Jackie Chan did not have a spicy enough
experience did one person does someone
want to say if they want to push it a
single-level further Clint gave me a
little bit this stuff yesterday
it's oregano oil he takes it because
it's healthy I don't get it it's a it's
an essential oil but I put a few drops
casually in my mouth and I thought I was
gonna die how does having an allergic
reaction who's so slight oh it's oregano
not spicy right wrong drops this is
concentrated freaking us knew it see if
you can handle this
Clint what the hell is this dude it's
not hot it's like your whole mouth is
like numb now right this is for internal
use they Luke one drop in for fluid
ounces that was horrible that was worse
than the kimchi been here a week yet and
he's already made me eat two nasty
things
I'm getting now is that [ __ ] my throat
it's uh that's like it's lit its pepper
blaze yeah